Trascrizione: Matteo Maggiò
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Chi di voi ha mai visto,
o conosce, questo pesce qui?
Proviamo a fare per alzata di mano, ok?
Magari qualcuno lo ha visto per mare,
altri lo conoscono.
Bene, dai: guardatevi intorno.
Tenete la mano alzata,
quanti l'hanno alzata.
Okay, perfetto: qualche mano su.
Per chi di voi non lo conoscesse,
ve lo dico subito:
questo qui è il pesce luna.
È il più grande pesce osseo
che esiste sulla terra,
quindi un pesce con le spine.
Questo pesce è una visione
molto comune, per chi vive il mare.
Spesso, lui nuota molto lentamente;
e quindi, gli animali e le altre alghe
gli si attaccano
sulla superficie del corpo.
E allora lui, che è molto furbo,
per liberarsene si sdraia di lato,
sulla superficie del mare,
a prendere proprio il sole,
aspettando che i raggi solari
brucino questi animali,
oppure che altri animali,
come i gabbiani, li possono mangiare.
Perché poi, alla fine,
non ho ancora ben capito
se per pigrizia o per astuzia,
la natura trova sempre
le soluzioni più pratiche:
dovremmo, veramente,
prenderla come esempio.
Molti di voi, oggi,
hanno alzato la mano, è vero,
perché il pesce luna, con le sue pinne
che sembrano un po' quelle di uno squalo,
è un pesce che si vede spesso
da chi naviga il mare.
Eppure, questo pallino grigio qui
ci dice tutt'altro.
Questo bollino viene
dalla lista rossa della IUCN,
l'Unione Internazionale
per la conservazione della Natura,
dove tutte le specie esistenti sulla Terra
vengono classificate in:
non a rischio; a rischio;
o in pericolo, in via d'estinzione.
Il pesce luna, però,
come più di 13.000 altre specie
solamente nel Mar Mediterraneo,
rientra in quest'altra categoria:
"data deficient", data-carenti.
Ciò vuol dire che la comunità scientifica
non ha abbastanza informazioni,
seppur sia un pesce che si avvista spesso,
per sapere se questo animale
è in via d'estinzione oppure no.
Solamente nel Mar Mediterraneo,
una ogni sei specie marine
rientrano in questa categoria.
E se non sappiamo dove sono e come stanno,
non possiamo proteggerle.
Il mare è grandissimo, lo sappiamo bene:
copre il 71% della superficie
del nostro pianeta.
È profondo, in alcuni luoghi,
più di dieci km:
eppure, gli scienziati stimano
che noi ne abbiamo scoperto,
ed esplorato, meno del cinque per cento.
E ancora, solamente nel Mediterraneo
delle specie marine sono 2000,
le nuove specie
che ogni giorno e ogni anno
aggiungiamo ai nostri registri.
Un mare grandissimo,
che però non conosciamo molto bene,
ed è essenziale alla vita.
E forse, un po' è proprio questo
che mi ha sempre attratto del mare:
l'ignoto e il mistero,
il fatto di non conoscerlo molto bene.
Alla fine, tutti i numeri
di cui ho appena parlato
non sono altro che un modo
che la scienza ci dà
per avvicinarci un po' di più
a questo mistero,
che però da sempre ha ispirato
la storia e la letteratura.
Gli antichi greci e romani, per esempio,
non riuscivano a darsi spiegazioni
alle grandi masse d'acqua
che mandavano le navi
a scoglio, improvvisamente -
che oggi sappiamo sono le correnti.
E allora, un po' per rispondere
alle loro domande,
si inventavano storie,
e leggende, di mostri marini,
come per esempio
quello di Scilla e Cariddi.
Tra l'altro, io a Scilla -
un piccolo paesino in Calabria,
non in Sicilia, a Messina -
ci sono proprio cresciuta,
tra questi scogli qui.
È un po' forse come faceva Omero,
guardando le correnti,
e narrando di sirene,
Io guardavo queste correnti,
veloci come autostrade,
che lasciavano quasi la scia negli scogli;
e questi scogli che, di anno in anno,
cambiavano posizione
con le mareggiate invernali.
Ero curiosa, ed estremamente affamata
di avvicinarmi un po' di più
a questo mistero.
Amavo i libri di storia e letteratura:
però, a un certo punto, quelle parole
non mi sono bastate più.
E allora, per cercare
di dare risposta alle mie domande,
ho deciso di rivolgermi alla scienza.
Nei miei studi, tra il Galles
e l'Inghilterra,
ho avuto l'onore di avere accanto a me
una persona che ha cercato
di dare risposte -
anzi, ne ha trovate qualcuna -
ad alcune delle domande più misteriose
della biologia marina:
quella dei mari profondi.
Nel 2018, sono diventata
assistente di ricerca
della dottoressa
Eve Southward, che vedete qui:
un mito della biologia marina
internazionale, in tutto il mondo.
Lei, alla veneranda età di 87 anni,
con il suo carrellino,
ogni giorno continuava a recarsi
presso l'associazione
di biologia marina inglese
per fare ricerca.
Negli anni '70, il Governo inglese diceva:
"Dobbiamo proteggere i mari profondi".
E allora,
Eve e tutto il suo team di ricerca
partivano per spedizioni
nei canyon più profondi
e misteriosi della Norvegia.
Andavano a raccogliere campioni,
a scattare foto:
ma soprattutto, a raccogliere
dati, informazioni.
Io scannerizzavo, aiutavo Eve
a catalogare queste foto,
sognando anche un po'
su quelle storie di spedizioni.
Lavorare accanto a lei è stato bellissimo:
però c'è una cosa che lei ripeteva spesso,
e che continua a riecheggiare
tutt'oggi nella mia mente.
Lei diceva: cercare di proteggere il mare,
senza però avere dati,
informazioni per capirlo
è un po' come cercare di guarire
una malattia che, però,
non conosciamo davvero.
I dati, infatti,
sono il linguaggio
che abbiamo a disposizione
per interpretare il mondo che ci circonda:
e di conseguenza, capire il modo migliore
per poterlo proteggere.
Non serve essere un esperto,
per capire la gravità
di un grafico del genere,
i cui colori sempre più scuri
ci mostrano la velocità
di riscaldamento dell'oceano
a livello storico, attuale e futuro.
E non solo: anche sulla superficie,
sotto i 200 metri, e sotto i 1000.
La situazione è gravissima:
ci fa vedere, veramente,
l'imminenza della crisi climatica
attualmente in atto.
Però, questa gradazione di colori
ci aiuta, anche, a guidare
le nostre azioni future,
a regolare le vele.
Infatti, sul report come questo,
della Commit internazionale
per i cambiamenti climatici,
si basano tutte le nostre leggi,
legislazioni e azioni
per mitigare la crisi climatica in atto.
E alla fine, report come questi
non sono altro che un mucchio di dati
raccolti da ricercatori,
da stazioni di ricerca,
da navi da ricerca,
che messi all'interno di un computer
ci ritornano indietro scenari come questi,
come per esempio fanno, anche,
le previsioni meteorologiche.
E questi scenari ci aiutano
a guidare le nostre leggi,
che di conseguenza hanno un'influenza
sulle azioni che compiamo ogni giorno.
Però, come dicevamo prima,
il mare è grande:
e per avere degli scenari accurati
ci servirebbero veramente
tanti, tanti dati.
E gli scienziati come Eve,
in realtà, non sono tanti:
anzi, sono veramente, veramente pochi.
Ma allora, com'è che possiamo raccogliere
tutti i dati di cui abbiamo bisogno,
per proteggere la vastità dell'oceano?
Prendiamo una regata:
tante barche che si sfidano
a chi va più veloce,
sfruttando la forza del vento.
Se guardassimo il sistema
di geolocalizzazione
alla fine di tutte le competizioni,
spesso ci ritroveremmo
immagini del genere:
una serie di scie colorate -
che poi sono le scie della barca -
che si intersecano e coprono,
spesso, aree vastissime.
Adesso, immaginate se ognuna
di queste barche, mentre naviga,
avesse a bordo dei sistemi
per monitorare il mare mentre veleggia.
Avrebbero raccolto dati
e informazioni utilissime
per proteggere un ambiente
che li fa stare bene,
mentre praticano lo sport che amano.
Questo può essere applicato
a qualsiasi sport:
è un numero innumerevole di connessioni
in cui le persone che vivono il mare,
attraverso gli sport all'aria aperta,
diventano gli occhi e le mani
di cui la scienza ha bisogno.
Adesso, non è che questa pratica
l'ho inventata proprio io:
si chiama "Citizen Science",
scienza del cittadino:
e risale circa agli anni '80,
quando è stata inserita
nel dizionario, banalmente.
A me piace pensare, però,
che connessioni come queste,
i giochi di squadra
tra gli sportivi e gli scienziati
siano un po' come funziona
un ecosistema marino
in cui ognuno - ogni specie,
ogni animale - ha un ruolo ben preciso.
Che, però, non gioca solamente
per il suo benessere,
ma per il benessere di tutto l'ecosistema.
Il gioco è proprio fare
le connessioni giuste,
ed è quello che stiamo facendo
nella startup che abbiamo creato
proprio qui a Genova,
dove connettiamo chi ama e vive il mare
con chi lo ama
e lo studia per proteggerlo.
Ve lo dico in parole povere:
avete presente Tinder,
l'applicazione di dating?
Sì: chi dice no, non ci credo.
(Risate)
Esatto: però, invece di trovare
il compagno della vostra vita,
noi connettiamo gli scienziati
che ci dicono di che dati hanno bisogno
con gli sportivi che vivono
il mare ogni giorno,
che li possono raccogliere: win win.
Per esempio, gli scienziati ci dicono
che hanno bisogno di dati sul pesce luna,
o su altri animali di cui non conosciamo
la loro distribuzione,
dove sono più fragili,
dove si riproducono.
E allora, noi insegniamo
alle persone che vivono il mare
attraverso gli sport come l'apnea,
la vela, la subacquea, il kayak
e chi più ne ha più ne metta -
come identificare questi animali,
farci sapere dove sono,
in quanti sono, cosa stanno facendo;
e di conseguenza, noi possiamo
guidare gli scienziati
per i luoghi dove questi animali
sono più fragili.
O ancora, di plastica in mare
se ne parla tantissimo:
però, spesso, le grandi navi da ricerca
non riescono ad avvicinarsi alla costa,
per esempio alla foce dei fiumi
o vicino alle nostre città,
dove l'inquinamento
potrebbe essere anche maggiore.
E quindi, noi cosa facciamo?
Ci trasciniamo dietro i nostri kayak
delle piccole reti da monitoraggio,
che rastrellano il mare alla ricerca
di piccoli frammenti di plastiche,
di microplastiche.
Noi poi li mandiamo agli scienziati,
che ci fanno sapere
di che materiale sono fatti,
le contano;
e quindi cerchiamo di arginare i danni.
O ancora, ritornando
alle barchette della regata:
questa qui è "Gin Tonic".
Se state cercando un drink,
non lo troverete,
perché sto parlando della barca.
È una piccola barca di sei metri e mezzo,
poco più grande di un kayak:
forse neanche la lunghezza
della scritta "TEDxGenova".
Una piccola barca che,
proprio in questo periodo,
il prossimo anno attraverserà
l'Oceano Atlantico
portando a bordo
non solo il suo velista da solo,
ma anche una serie
di piccoli sensori da monitoraggio
che potrebbero essere utilizzati
su tutte le barche in futuro.
Una piccola barca che, però,
potrebbe contribuire
a rendere più accurati
grandi report sui cambiamenti climatici:
e di conseguenza, influenzare
le azioni che compiamo ogni giorno.
Tanti sport, che ci fanno stare bene,
per tanti dati che permettono a noi,
e al mare, di stare meglio.
E tra l'altro, i dati
che abbiamo raccolto finora
ci dicono
che se agiamo adesso,
siamo ancora in tempo.
Nel 2020, i maggiori scienziati
del mare di tutta Europa
si sono riuniti,
hanno preso tutti i dati
di cui avevano a disposizione sul mare,
li hanno messi in un computer,
e hanno pubblicato questo articolo,
che con una sola frase ha ridato speranza
a tutta la comunità
di scienziati internazionali.
Loro sostengono che
"un sostanziale ricovero dell'abbondanza,
struttura e funzione della vita marina
potrebbe essere raggiunto entro il 2050
se, giustamente, le maggiori pressioni,
incluse il cambiamento climatico,
saranno mitigate".
E questo è possibile perché il mare
è estremamente resiliente.
Così come ci sta dando
una serie di campanelli d'allarme
che le cose non stanno
tantissimo andando nel verso giusto,
se gliene viene data la possibilità,
lasciandolo anche un attimino stare,
lui si riorganizza sempre
per permettere la vita.
Quando da piccola guardavo i miei scogli,
che si spostavano con le mareggiate,
notavo spesso come le parti
scoperte degli scogli
si riempivano di alghe di altri animali,
nel momento in cui venivano toccate
dall'acqua salata.
Perché alla fine, se ci pensate -
facciamo uno sforzo d'immaginazione -
tutto quello che mettiamo in acqua
prima o poi a un certo punto prende vita.
Pensate al di sotto di una boa,
o una barca ferma in porto; o anche noi.
Io, sinceramente,
ogni volta che mi tuffo in acqua
mi sento di prendere un po' vita.
E forse, la chiave per proteggere il mare
sta proprio qui,
nel tornare a tuffarci nell'acqua salata
che ci fa stare così bene.
Con curiosità, però, avvicinandoci
sempre un po' di più a quel mistero.
Il naturalista David Attenborough
in uno dei suoi documentari,
penso abbia riassunto
questo pensiero molto, molto bene,
dicendo che "Nessuno proteggerà
quello che non gli interessa,
e a nessuno interesserà
quello che non hanno
mai realmente vissuto".
E se i dati sono lo strumento
che abbiamo a disposizione
per proteggere il mare,
allora andiamolo a vivere,
questo mare, tutti insieme,
facendo lo sport che ci piace di più.
E mentre ci divertiamo,
ricordiamoci che tutti
possiamo partecipare.
E raccogliere insieme,
veramente, un mare di dati.
Grazie.
(Applausi)